hi my name is Quest
love I love that your name still cracks
you up after all these
years being as though this podcast saved
my life during the pandemic oh
um H I've heard every adjective used to
describe how does one want to be friends
with Conan however um before I give the
the ad
yes I'm already going to break Jeff gold
blum's record
yeah yes go for it but as a Creator and
a creator that relies on an editor I
want to know who's the person that has
to extend Jack White's padding foot yeah
so right
now so no no you're going to do the
extended 12 Loop
it wait you're going to hear Jack's foot
get tired and slow down and lose the
beat keep going Jack we got to get PR
love to the Finish Line wait by the time
by the time I got to the gold Bloom
episode I was like wait a minute did he
call up Jack to to custom make extra
feet and then I
realized it's it's only when I became a
nightmare to my own editor that I
realized that you're going to have to
figure out how many measures of four are
you going to end
I'm going to put a kick drum Mallet on a
metronome next to a Kick Drum and then
go take a
nap I love how we're talking how long
it's going as it's going as it's going
as it's going that's right can we just
do the entire podcast this is going to
be oh my God go for
it that's a first yeah um yeah I I am I
had so many adjectives to use um I'm
just GNA go simple which of course none
of this is
simple I'm fine with it
however all that for I'm fine with it
beautiful I'm fine with it no
but this the
thing that's how I feel about a
colonoscopy like I'm fine with it it
gets the job done I don't want it but
here's the thing I I was initially
grinned and
angered that you guys dared pitch me to
do this podcast without met or son like
literally you're kind of like Charlie
Brown like not saying like you're not
the star of your own Halloween special
you want the full experience yes and you
want to make sure that um pig pen and uh
the girl with red hair are there I'm
sorry no I think what he's saying is
wait you're frea how you wait wait wait
time out minimize them as much as I
could the red hair which one is she cuz
no one knows her name I want which one's
the one that always pushes is that Lucy
that Lucy Vel you're very much Lucy to
his CH yeah she has a last name Lucy Vel
oh my God how do you know well because
she is the brother of lonus vanel that's
right oh Lucy vanel I I have a knack for
attracting a lot of Lucy Van pelts in my
life oh like proverbial uh football uh
tugging rer just real quick are we still
in the in yeah I was going to say okay
okay uh I'm fine with it and Q music
yeah Q music I'm
sure all right well here's what I'll say
Let Me Clear something up right away yes
we I go to New York occasionally and
when I'm in New York we get whoever's
available in New York we've been wanting
to talk to you for a long time you were
available and then uh and this was
pitched through someone else and then I
hear no he really wants to do it with
the whole gang and I thought wonderful a
mistake but B fine I'm fine with that
I'm glad what saying is your excuse
today
Conan we'll take it from here all right
I'll pipe down no man it's it's it's
important you know yeah you're fine with
being here I have so many questions for
them and you know but this is nice well
yeah I like this listen this is when
you're on this podcast it's your podcast
so feel free to uh ask them anything you
want but are we really going to be
friends yeah okay cuz the one you want
do you want that I honestly want it yes
okay I'm in if okay so the transition
week of you doing the last of late night
yep before taking over the tonight's
show yeah before uh we came in we as in
uh uh uh the Fallon people yep came to
do it you were like walking in the
hallway or whatever and instantly you
know you know when people feel like they
know someone mhm sort of like a poster
on the wall whatever like you don't know
them but they feel like they know you
and instantly I was like oh man me me
and Kiger get along famously this is GNA
be awesome and then I turned the corner
even though I've been on your show maybe
three to four times you've been on three
times with the roots yeah and but I
don't know why I never took into account
that you're a
giant or maybe because maybe I'm sitting
behind a drum set yep and I didn't take
into account how tall you were and plus
you know I'm on that's been that's when
being on television was like really like
a big deal so I wasn't in my right mind
now it's just like okay I'll show up
but I saw you walking down the hallway
and instantly I just started to shrink
like oh no he's he's too tall to be he's
too tall to be my
friend you know what's so funny that you
say that is well you've been with me
Sona it's the only thing people talk
about when I walk around I get that all
the time and people act like I've lied
to them so when I go through like points
people people are like hey man you
I didn't know you were This Tall it's
like I didn't what did I do well cuz you
have approachable energy I'll say that
you and leader who should not be named
45 are probably the two of the
most I'm glad you got that where's this
going you two have a you two have a
analogy and it's not here it's not here
it's it's it's your it's a little bit
hair both of you are tall like even he I
didn't know that he was tall how tall is
he yeah he's a big guy he's like 64 is
he really no no no no no no no dude his
son o old boy is like 68 already he's
like what 12 years old parents hug no no
no but no Trump is not 6'4 but the thing
is what's that 63 yeah and there's a big
difference between 63 and 64 63
it's an incalculable difference when my
afro's out when my afro's out people
think I'm like 63 64 I'm like 62 maybe
61 so wait a minute you say I'm just
keeping track here you're fine quote
fine with being my friend and you liken
me to Donald Trump in my approachability
and Charlie Brown and Charlie Brown you
know what it is okay
[Music]
um we're going to wrap this up very soon
right trust me Show's going to be I told
you guys I'm warning you guys what
you're in for no I'm I'm pretty much
going to be uh either the tricks rabbit
or uh the
cuckoo what's the coco p for Cocoa Puff
Sunny that's a he has a name wow Vel and
sunny yeah wait wait how's his name
Sunny Puffs I don't think the cuckoo for
Cocoa Puffs was he he had a name I know
cuz I take my sugar cereals very that's
insane that you know that I don't know
what to say I'm not proud it's the same
thing it just lives there like Van Pelt
I was just thinking the same thing when
you Pelt I respect uh but excuse me I'm
sorry but you shouldn't know the name do
you know Captain crunch's little
Sidekicks sure Smedley the soggies well
oh the S well I know smedley's the
elephant um oh yes that's right yeah
well Smedley was for peanut butter
crunch wasn't he maybe and then Jim
bakus did Captain's voice right okay am
I ruining the show by rabbit hoing you
guys no no no no in this is a good and
by the way we're going to play this for
a neurologist later yeah and we're going
to come back we're going to come back
with your diagnosis and then we're going
to get you on the right medicine well my
my whole point my whole point was my
whole point was that uh each each serial
commercial starts the same like those
guys try to be cool Cal and Collective
about it and then yes Midway in the plot
then they lose their excitement and
suddenly you realize you have a crazy
person on your hand yeah so that's
exactly which is why I ask you are are
these guys into micro doing at all or
edibles and my answer was no right what
your answer for yourself no my answer
was yeah I'm into it you're you're not
into it I'm square that way yeah I
burned myself out in my 30s we talked
about this on the way in today yeah yeah
yeah well next all right appearance
number four I like the way that I'm
already manifesting my like I I want to
be this Sanja burnhard to your Letterman
so trust me wait and also am I
alienating your demographic with all
these old ass references no no let me
quickly ask you what is your go-to kid
cereal
um I am peanut butter Captain Crunch all
day it is fantastic that stuff
it is amazing do you know about the
history of cereal do you know why cereal
was invented was this the Kellog don't
masturbate stuff yes yes I I'm a little
bit familiar with this story but since
you began go ahead oh that's all I
basically know well use a day Kelloggs
was a 7-Day avenus um guy uh he had a
wife and I guess even they slept in
separate sleeping Corners they adopted
their children separate vaginas
yeah oh God am I going to get canceled
after this appearance no um you're being
canceled during the
appearance so what happens is I I guess
he feels as though whatever is used to
make beef uh the whatever drugs are
injected in the cow or the pig whatever
um that it's making America um closer to
that of Sodom and Gomorrah yep and so he
figures that a vegetarian diet will
cause us to stop procreating and and
yeah and so um he invents a
tasty counterpart to stop us from
masturbating which is cornflakes that's
yeah well the original slogan for
cornflakes was now with 30% less
that's an
actual and it
was but it's true can I can I work here
yes you can work here wait take my
job